whenever I want to learn how a movie is
put together one of the first things I
do is get a pen and paper and just count
the shots seriously it's not very
technical and it's a bit tedious but
just tallying every time there's a cut
forces you to see things in a different
way it kills the illusion just enough
that the nuts and bolts start to come
into view
for example let's take a look at PT
Anderson's there will be blood already
by the third shot I noticed a camera
technique that would be used again and
again throughout the film this heavy
emphasis on double and triple framing in
single shots Anderson and
cinematographer Robert Elliot were
clearly interested in making a movie
comprised largely of long takes but they
keep up the momentum by collapsing
multiple shots into one things never
dragged on or get too boring which is
definitely a consideration when your
movie is two and a half hours long in
fact by the end of the 14 and a half
minute dialogue free introduction I was
struck by the length of the shots and by
how few there actually were 73 to be
exact and 14 and a half minutes / 73
means that each shot on average was
about 12 seconds long that's a really
long average shot length by today's
standards and something I wasn't
expecting Anderson to keep up throughout
the rest of the film was graphed by the
way showing that average shot lengths
have decreased over the years comes from
the work of Barry salt who's been
writing about film metrics since the 60s
and 70s and if you want to dive deeper
into metrics like these I highly
recommend visiting his websites in the
metrics where all kinds of data is
listed out for literally thousands of
movies but I think the best insights
come from doing the counting yourself
for example one of the things that
occurs to you watching there will be
blood like this is that the value of a
simple cut increases as the number of
cuts decreases
it's amazing how impactful a cut can be
when you're not watching them happen at
breakneck speed I don't mean to say that
films with more cuts are necessarily
worse or better just at a movie like
there will be blood finds a lot of power
in a common cinematic device the moment
you make a decision it's it's very it's
in stark relief to the audience and
there's there's a lot of a big spotlight
on now I'm changing perspective now I'm
telling you something else with soapy
cut the stickin or says the contrast of
each is dialed up considerably and like
daniel plainview anderson and tikka nor
mine that contrast for meaning a lot of
times it's literal cutting between dark
frames and bright frames or loud moments
and quiet ones just a quick side note
this sequence right here by the way
shots 256 to 263 are the quickest
cutting in the film by far anderson used
so few shots that Ticknor had the find
ways to artificially add more cuts to
build up the momentum of this moment you
can actually see that shots 258 and 260
are just alternate angles of the shots
that came before them it's really good
editing anyway other times the contrast
is personal if you wanted to suggest
that 2 characters were different sides
of the same coin for example arch-rivals
but cut from the same cloth
all you need is two shots 1 tracking
into a character mumbling to himself
bathed in light
another tracking out from a character
mumbling to himself covered in shadow
what I realized after a while is that
there's a domino effect longer takes
mean more impactful cuts mean more
attention to composition if you want
your framing to mean something then your
cuts up to mean something because the
cut is where the viewer really sees the
framing and they see it with a fresh
memory almost an after image the frame
that came before sometimes it is
actually a memory and if you want your
cuts to mean something then you have to
use them sparingly and with care every
single shot is filled with a kind of
anticipation because these cuts are
registered consciously on the viewers
mind we're all waiting for the next one
to come and everything around JB gun
sure PT Anderson knows that anticipation
is just a form of focus and he's great
at channeling that heightened focus
toward the performances we have an actor
as magnetic as Daniel day-lewis the
longer the take the more you hang on his
every word and pause I see the worst in
people and me I don't need to look past
seeing them to get away watching this
movie I noticed that conversations like
this are the place with the most
frequent editing on average a necessity
of shopper / shot but even here
everything is deliberate this sequence
for example is 16 shots and three and a
half minutes ticking or holds firm on
the wide until Eli makes the key comment
what is it that project nears good Lords
guidance of course within develop news
he cuts in but only a little while
Daniel thinks he's still dealing with
the father and when it's clear Eli is
the prime negotiator the scene locks on
close-ups
as they battle back and forth though I
don't know for sure it looks a lot like
ticking or extended the silences here to
augment the intensity that's good
it works giving the shots breathing room
on both sides of the dialogue far from
making the scene drag dials up the
emotion considerably and something
Henderson does throughout the film
close-ups are used again and again for
moments of silence just as much for
important pieces of dialogue Vicki
Anderson like the Coen brothers is great
at casting for faces and he wants us to
watch them as much as listen and of
course he wants us to watch daniel
plainview the most who corrodes with
bitterness across a series of close-ups
even as he finds success and the
solitude that he craves I drink your
water I drink it on every day I drink
the blood of lamb bandage tract there
are six hundred and seventy eight shots
and there will be for over two and a
half hours that means that each shot is
thirteen point three seconds on average
more than the introduction the movie is
remarkably consistent on this front each
hour or half-hour
taken alone will average somewhere
around 12 to 14 seconds maybe this is
what gives the movie its steady but
unrelenting takes the feeling that
you're watching train you can't stop
there are tons of ways to deconstruct a
movie but it's amazing what you can
learn just from looking at the shots one
by one as they go by for many of us
loving a film means wanting to know how
it works with the spirit of an engineer
we take it apart twist it turn it bend
it and put it back together or at least
we try to a great movie we'll never give
up all its secrets but it will give up
some of this episode was brought to you
by the great courses plus the great
courses plus is an on-demand video
learning service which basically means
it's got around 7,000 online video
lecture series from some great
professors about all kinds of subjects
math history archaeology art you name it
one that I think you should really check
out is called inexplicable universe
unsolved mysteries by Neil deGrasse
Tyson which is super heady and
interesting and it's taught by Neil
Tyson which is all you should need to
know if you go to the great courses plus
comm slash nerdwriter or click the link
in the description you can get a 30 day
free trial after that annual memberships
are $14.99 a month and monthly
memberships are $19.99 a month thanks
everybody I'll see you next time